[Music]
Khloe Kardashian reveals enormous
rebuilding is underway with boyfriend
Tristan Thompson the 33 year old reality
star took to Twitter on Monday to
confirm the couple is on the men after a
fan questioned Khloe's decision to stay
with the 27 year old basketball star
since news broke he cheated on her
multiple times while she was pregnant
with their daughter true while he
clapped back you have no knowledge of
what goes on in our household or the
enormous rebuilding mistakes to even
coexist I'm proud of my strength a
source told ET last week Khloe and her
family have forgiven Tristan some advice
is great but it's also not what you say
it's how you say it the candid Twitter
exchange comes just one day after Khloe
was spotted sporting a huge diamond ring
while celebrating one of Tristan's best
friend's birthdays at boa Steakhouse
though it was reported throughs parents
seemed tense during the celebrations and
I witnessed lzt they appeared in great
spirits
Khloe even took pictures with a few
restaurant goers and was smiling from
ear to ear they toasted to each other
and the birthday boy during two separate
occasions throughout the night
you